hey David are you now ready to talk
about who Joe Biden will likely select
as his vice presidential running mate
yes I am I've made it a point not to put
the cart before the horse
so back in 2017 and 2018 before the
midterms people would say what are you
thinking about Democratic primary
presidential candidates and I said I'm
thinking about the midterm I'll talk
about that later when we still had a
primary going on people would call into
the show or ask me during live streams
who do you see as the best running mate
for whoever is the nominee and we didn't
know who the nominee was going to be yet
and I said let's take it one step at a
time so I'm gonna answer the question as
it's asked which is who do I believe is
likely I think right now the top three
possibilities for Joe Biden given that
he said he would be selecting that he
would be selecting a woman as his
running mate would be in no particular
order Kamala Harris Amy Klobuchar and I
would like to think Elizabeth Warren now
I've read conflicting things about the
likelihood of a possible war in a
running mate selection and a number of
opinions are she would be likely to be
doing something in Biden's
administration but not VP we've heard
about Warren possibly as Treasury
secretary that would be quite a change
from Stephen minuchin we've heard about
Warren possibly a Secretary of State a
lot is being floated around so in no
particular order I think the most likely
or qumola Warren and Amy now that being
said there's some other interesting
names that are that are increasingly
being discussed Gretchen Whitmer the
governor of Michigan is increasingly
being discussed her response to corona
virus has been notable I don't know
whether to call it good or bad you know
a lot of the responses that are called
really good are in states with a ton of
cases New York is an example Michigan is
an example the argument would be well
they'd be even worse off if it weren't
for these governors in any case because
Trump has been going after her Gretchen
Whitmer is very much in the public eye
Michelle Obama's been floated around I
don't see it I just don't see it at all
Stacey Abrams who fell short of winning
the 2018 Georgia gubernatorial election
- Brian Kemp he was both running in that
election and running the election as
Secretary of State interesting right
Stacey Abrams lost she's being mentioned
as a possible Biden running mate I would
be shocked if it's Stacey Abrams it just
doesn't feel like that's the direction
it's going and then a few people have
emailed me saying that Bernie surrogate
Nina Turner should be selected by Joe
Biden I see zero chance of that I just
don't see any way that that becomes a
reality Tammy Duckworth has been
mentioned I think that would be an
interesting pick although it seems less
likely than Amy kamala may be Warren and
then also the ideas has been
increasingly floated some people are
talking about andrew Cuomo governor of
New York should replace Biden as the
presidential candidate I don't see how
you make that happen again
unless something incredibly serious
happened to Joe Biden I don't see that
but the idea of drafting Cuomo as VP of
course Biden would have to go back on
having said he was going to pick a woman
I think that would look really bad and I
don't see Biden doing it unless
circumstances that I can't even imagine
come to fruition but that's been
mentioned as well abandon his call to
select a woman and go with Andrew Cuomo
very high favorability and and sort of
in the public eye as a result of his
coronavirus handling again New York with
a crazy amount of cases Cuomo
communicating well communicating almost
daily and turning things around and
getting getting to the peak much faster
than many other states it's an idea it
probably would be a helpful one in a
vacuum but going back on his word about
a female running mate may have been a
problem this is why many people say you
never want to commit to any identity
boxes being checked by your candidate
because then you're artificially
limiting yourself Biden's calculation
was saying he would select the woman
would help him more than it would
potentially limit his choices and do
damage in the future so if you said
David you've got a bet who is it going
to be I I'm leaning towards Kamala I'm
leaning towards Kamala and this is not
an endorsement of Kamala in any way but
if you said I have to bet on only one
eye I would guess Kamala Harris I think
we will sue
no Biden letting Bernie know several
weeks ago that he was starting to vet
vice presidential candidates and we will
all know very very soon we have a
tremendous I almost a mix terrific and
tremendous we have a tremendous bonus
show for you today two ways to get
instant access to the bonus show become
a member at join pakman.com or become a
patron at patreon.com slash david pakman
show both are instant almost instant 30
seconds okay with mild computer
familiarity and you will be able to
check out my crazy police related story
that I told on the Monday bonus show
from this past weekend don't miss it
join pakman.com patreon.com slash david
pakman show